Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and  Associates the sponsors of this segment  explains what the penalties are for a  first-time DUI charge  I'm Eric polaskios welcome to the legal  minute today's question is what are the  penalties for a first-time DUI charge if  you're found guilty of a DUI there are  many penalties first you will likely  spend between two days and up to six  months in jail you'll have to perform 24  to 96 hours of community service you'll  have to attend DUI school and pay fines  between 400 to 1 000 you also have to  attend a DUI Victim Impact Panel where  you have to listen to people who've been  personally affected by someone drinking  and driving on top of that your license  may be suspended for up to 185 days if  your blood alcohol level is above a 0.18  then you will face even more penalties  if you're accused of driving Under the  Influence it's important that you call  an experienced attorney right away I'm  Eric Palacios this has been the legal  minute